au moment de son vol inaugural en juin
1939 le focke wulf 190 était
incontestablement l'avion de combat le
plus moderne du monde
grâce à son énorme puissance de feu est
à son niveau de performance
exceptionnelle ce petit appareil
amateurs radial disposer de tout le
potentiel pour surclasser l'ensemble des
chasseurs alliés de son temps
la mise en service en 1941 il allait
connaître un succès immédiat
les pilotes alliés à qui l'affligent à
tant de pertes le surnommèrent bientôt
l'oiseau bush
pendant quatre ans le fw 190 servi sur
tous les théâtres d'opération allemand
depuis l'afrique du nord jusqu'à la
russe il fut par la quantité le deuxième
avions de la luftwaffe et l'un des
chasseurs les plus redoutables de son
époque
sa grande polyvalence lui permettait de
remplir avec toujours autant
d'efficacité différents types de mission
à la fin de la guerre il avait été
produit à plus de 20000 exemplaires
outre les nombreuses variantes en tant
que chasseur et chasseurs bombardiers
d'autres versions ont vu le jour comme
celle de l'appareil d' attaque au sol le
chasseur lance-torpilles le chasseur de
nuit ainsi que des versions
d'entraînement et de reconnaissance en
1941 le focke wulf 190 faisait
l'admiration à la fois des pilotes
allemands et des pilotes alliés beaucoup
d'entre eux le considérer comme le
meilleur appareil à moteur radial de
toute l'histoire de la luftwaffe et à la
différence du bf 109 qui excédaient
rapidement son potentiel de
développement
la machine de compte tant qu demeura un
adversaire redoutable pour la majorité
des chasseurs alliés et ce jusqu'à la
fin de la guerre
la société faut que golf vi
officiellement le jour en janvier 1924
lorsque les pionniers de l'aviation
heinrich faut que et gor diouf
s'associèrent un célèbre homme
d'affaires de brême
werner neumann wulff avait été incorporé
dans l'armée de l'air allemande de dix
ans plus tôt et était devenu à la fin du
premier conflit mondial
un pilote accompli
fox occupa le poste de directeur
technique
henman quant à lui celui de directeur
commercial wulff de son côté 8 en charge
tout ce qui concernait les essais ans
cette société oriental dans les premiers
temps ses efforts vers la production
d'appareils légers de transport mais ne
connu aucune grande réussite commerciale
avant les années 30 en septembre 1931
faut que wulff fusionna avec la vieille
société albatros et beneficial dès lors
du savoir faire de ses meilleurs
ingénieurs au mois de novembre de la
même année l'usiné de brême vie
l'arrivée du très talentueux cours tank
cet ingénieur électricien qui possédait
déjà plus de 20 ans d'expérience en
aéronautique
celui nommé au poste de chef de projet
bon ça par heinrich phoques qui
s'intéressaient de plus en plus au
concept novateur de l'hélicoptère
démissionna du conseil d'administration
en 1932 pour fonder sa propre société
l'afocal organisme l'accession d'hitler
au pouvoir en 1933 entraîna une compet
transformation de l'industrie
aéronautique allemand qu tank assisté
d'une équipe d'ingénieurs exceptionnel
devant la force motrice de faux que
wulff qui reçu à leurs différentes
commande de prototype de la part du
nouveau ministère de l'air du reich le
rlm love phare ministériel
le f w 44 et stiglitz fut le premier
appareil pour lequel cette société reçu
de grosses commandes elles allaient
grâce à lui commencé à jouir d'une
reconnaissance internationale
celui plan d'entraînement à deux places
servi dans la luftwaffe pendant plus de
dix ans il fut suivi d'un appareil
d'entraînement plus perfectionné le fw
56 grâce à cette machine qui servit plus
tard deux modèles auch tout cas fut le
premier fois que boulefa être
entièrement conçu et développé sous
l'unique responsabilité de cours tant qu
bat ensuite le f w 57
le premier avion tout métal de cette
société qui allait figurer parmi les
principaux protagonistes dans l'appel
d'offres du rlm en 1936 cette même année
une autre compétition du même type
proposa arado heinkel focke-wulf et
bayerisches fuchs iceberg
le contrat avec la luftwaffe portait
cette fois sur la production d'un
chasseur monoplace heinkel bfw et arado
avait toutefois opter pour la solution
du monoplan à ailes basses
de son côté le fw 159 de court temps
qu'était un avion à l aude victime
d'insurmontables problèmes au niveau de
100 trains d'atterrissage escamotable le
f w 159 ville comptera lui échapper
celui-ci revint au bf 109 2 mai schmid
cette expérience avait toutefois permis
à temps car son équipe d'engranger de
nouvelles connaissances en trois ans en
tant que produit alors deux remarquables
allure
après des essais en vol particulièrement
concluant le f w 189 baptisé le hibou
fut commandés massivement pour servir de
simple avion de reconnaissance
temps même s'il avait déjà été largement
utilisés avant la guerre les alliés
ignorèrent son existence jusqu'en 1941
année où ils lui donnèrent le surnom d'
à upholland des armes égales
sur le front de l'est cet appareil donna
toute satisfaction
de plus sa formidable maniabilité en
faisait une cible difficile pour les
chasseurs d'autre part sa structure
était exceptionnellement résistante plus
d'une fois l'un d'entre eux réussi à
regagner sa base
après avoir subi de sérieux dommages au
niveau des aires produits pour les vols
commerciaux l'an courrier de la deutsche
lufthansa
le f w200 condor établi quant à lui
d'impressionnants record de durée de vol
sur des destinations telles que new york
ou tokyo
cela lui permit de décrocher par la
suite de nombreuses commandes à
l'exportation en tant qu'avion militaire
le f w200 effectué à de longues missions
de reconnaissance et servi notamment à
filer les navires il jouait alors le
rôle de postes de commandement pour les
hoops toutefois à cause de la faiblesse
de sa structure il ne fut jamais
beaucoup apprécié des équipages
à la fin 2009 137 la production du bf
109 battait son plein le succès de cet
appareil était essentiellement due à son
moteur le daimler-benz six ans ce 12
cylindres en ligne disposer en deux
rangées de cylindres parallèle était une
petite merveille de mécanique
cette présentation résulter de l'idée
selon laquelle un moteur londres et
trois se révèlerait plus aérodynamique
et permettrait donc à la viande obtenir
un gain de 8 aces significatif le
daimler benz 600 équipes a également le
méchant smit bf 110 un chasseur bimoteur
la fable traîner obtenu grâce à cette
forme aérodynamique constituer un atout
majeur pour les ingénieurs qui lorsqu'il
s'agit d'avions de chasse recherche
toujours un cas en matière de vitesse
et en 1937 le moteur en ligne de vins
quasiment la norme universelle pour les
chasseurs les week-ends britannique
était équipée du moteur merlin de
rolls-royce qui présentait les mêmes
caractéristiques puissance et forme
aérodynamique
voici le vote 141 un avion américain
d'avant guerre qui ne fut jamais adopté
par l'armée américaine
un exemplaire de cet appareil avait
cependant été vendus au japon et
certains fonctionnaires
l' empire du soleil levant ne s'en être
inspiré pour concevoir ses propres
chasseurs au lieu du moteur en ligne le
141 utilisait alors un moteur radial à
refroidissement par air les cylindres
étaient disposées en cercle autour du
vilebrequin moins aérodynamique que le
moteur en ligne celui ci était pourtant
très apprécié de l'ua sneg il offre
effectivement une meilleure fiabilité et
il présente l avantage de ne pas
nécessiter de radiateur il était en
outre beaucoup plus courts ce qui
permettait d'en marquer davantage
d'appareils sur le pont d'un
porte-avions la société pratt & whitney
poursuivi le développement du moteur
radial à refroidissement par air en tant
qu'alternative aux motos en ligne à
refroidissement par eau mais en dehors
des chasseurs de la navy on ne le
retrouve et que sur les avions de ligne
les bombardiers pour lesquels un moteur
aérodynamique ne constituait pas une
nécessité absolue
au début des années 30 quelques moteurs
pratt & whitney furent vendus à
l'allemagne avant d'être par la suite
produits sous licence par la société bmw
en dépit du succès rencontré par le bf
certaines personnes au sein de la
luftwaffe continuer à insister sur la
nécessité d'un second chasseurs
daimler-benz se trouvait alors dans
l'impossibilité de fournir davantage de
moteurs et dans ces conditions le projet
de phoques wulff un chasseur à moto
radial bmw fut adopté en tant que
solution de réserve
le nouvel avion de combat tant qu était
remarquablement profilés et surtout
solide
d'autre part sa construction était d'une
grande simplicité le fw 190 c'était un
petit chef-d'oeuvre lignes de production
du 190 sur mise en place dès les
premiers mois 2009 139 cet avion
n'allait pas seulement être produit en
masse mais ils allaient l'être en
recourant à de nombreux sous-traitants
chacun chargé de fabriquer des pièces
spécifiques en grande quantité
déjà en 1939 bien avant que l'allemagne
ne devint la cible des premiers raids de
bombardement le commandement allemand
avait compris l'intérêt de la production
de bath mais au moyen d'un réseau
décentralisé de fournisseurs en effet
disséminés à travers le pays ces petites
usines seraient des cibles
particulièrement difficile à atteindre
pour les bombardiers alliés avant la fin
de la guerre l'ensemble des pièces
composant le fw 190 provenaient alors de
24 usines différentes
le bois de cet appareil était
relativement élevée il pesé avec le
plein de carburant près de cape town 5
contre 3 tonnes 6 pour le bf 109
cette différence de poids s'expliquer
par la recherche d'une plus grande
résistance de l'appareil
les ingénieurs de phoques wolf
souhaitait qu'il pût faire face aux
pires conditions d'exploitation
toutefois une question subsiste et la
puissance supplémentaire du bmw dix huit
cylindres type 139 serait elle
suffisante pour compenser le supplément
de poids et de traîner du 190 par
rapport au bf 109
tous les constructeurs de moteurs en
ligne destiné à des chasseurs travaillé
déjà à plein temps pour la société mais
cherche midi est content que se retrouva
donc de ce fait dans l'obligation de
recourir à la technologie pourtant
impopulaire du moteur radial
le bf 109 se distinguait également du
190 par cl démontable assemblée au
fuselage par une unique poutre le fw 190
posséder quant à lui de très grosses à l
assemblée conjointement sur lesquels
venait se placer de part et d'autre le
fuselage les jointures était ensuite
recouverte d'une plaque destiné à offrir
une meilleure résistance et un gain
supplémentaire de vitesse tout cela
reflétait la philosophie de coop tant qu
un design simple les pièces solide et
utiliser au maximum toute la technologie
disponible
le moteur bmw fut bientôt prêt à être
installé sur le chasseur cet élément clé
de tout le projet devait être testées
selon les critères de la nouvelle
formule puissance poids et aérodynamisme
le 1er juin 1939
le pilote d'essai en vol de la société
focke wulf and saunders se retrouva sur
la piste de brême aux commandes du
premier prototype du 190 appelé v1 afin
de mettre ces nouvelles théories à
l'épreuve les caractéristiques de vol se
révélèrent tout à fait impressionnante
avec notamment une bonne stabilité une
incroyable amplitude de roulis et de
plonger au freinage ainsi qu'une
maniabilité peu connu il n'y avait
cependant pas que de bonnes nouvelles
lorsqu'ils posent à la pareille à nos
standards signal a effectivement un
grave problème de surchauffe du bmw
centrale
les vols suivants confirmèrent ce compte
rendu la fiabilité du moteur et est
gravement menacée et la température à
l'intérieur du cockpit atteignit
rapidement 45 degrés on décida alors de
remédier à cette surchauffe moteur en
remplaçant le livre d'eli ce par un
capot moteur ajusté
cette modification s'avérera bénéfique
mais ne résolu pas entièrement ce
problème qui allaient empoisonner le
programme de développement pendant
encore deux années après l'achèvement
des deux premiers prototypes les
améliorations se succédaient à un rythme
beaucoup moins rapide
d'autre part le messerschmitt 109 et est
maintenant bien intégré
mais dans ces conditions le ministère de
l'air du reich s'intéresser un peu moins
au football
les modifications et les essais se
poursuivirent tout au long de l'année
1940 le troisième prototype était équipé
du bmw 801 plus puissants tandis que
d'autres appareils utilisés des versions
courtes ou longues de l'est la de poudre
cependant les problèmes moteur persister
mais entre-temps le faut qu'au golf
était devenue une priorité absolue il
était temps de décider de son avenir
avant de s'engager le ministère de l'air
ordonnac une série d'essais comparatifs
fut réalisée pendant l'année 1941 en
mars
quelques pilotes très expérimentés de
l'escadre j26 assisté d'un groupe
d'ingénieurs de foca golf entamèrent des
essais complets sur un terrain situé
près de racheter
pendant les mois qui suivirent il
réalisait un programme complet
d'évaluation du prototype du fw 190
sable de pré-production et du bf 109 f
à la fin du mois de novembre la jg 26
commandé par adolphe gallant est à
également le 190 en conditions
opérationnelles lors de sa toute
première sortie dans les environs de
dunkerque à la fonte a en effet une
importante formation de spitfire là bien
que largement surpassé en nombre les 190
réussira à battre trois appareils
britanniques le 10 décembre
l'équipe d'évaluation de reichlin libre
à son rapport à basse altitude le focke
wulf se montrer plus rapide que le mais
cherche midi tandis qu il égalait ses
performances à une altitude comprise
entre quatre et cinq mille mètres
au-delà de 5000 mètres ses performances
diminuer fortement et le messerschmitt
se montrait alors plus rapide avec une
différence de 20 km heure
en piqué et ce depuis n'importe quelle
altitude
le 190 pouvait facilement surpassé le
sang neuf mais s'avérer nettement
inférieur lorsqu'il s'agissait de
l'ascension
il lui fallait quasiment une minute de
plus pour atteindre les 5000 m et encore
six minutes supplémentaires pour passer
à 10000 mètres
malgré cela ils disposaient d'un rayon
d'action plus étendu et il surclassait
totalement le sang neuf en termes de
maniabilité
grâce à ces gouverne nettement plus
souple le focke wulf pouvait à n'importe
quelle vitesse prendre des virages et
réaliser des tonneaux plus serré que le
messerschmitt
j'aimais beaucoup le fw 190 car c'était
un avion nettement supérieur aux et me
il était très maniable publié voler en
rase motte à haute altitude
vous pouviez faire tout ce que vous
vouliez il était vraiment formidable
pour ce qui est des inconvénients de ces
d'appareils lorsque vous vous présentiez
sur la piste de décollage
vous ne disposiez pas d'une très bonne
visibilité vous étiez gênés par ce gros
moteur radial et dans ces moments-là
fallait être très prudent à mais une
fois en l'air c'était un vrai plaisir
en dépit de son poids plus important et
de la limitation du champ de vision
cet avion offrez une grande sécurité au
sol grâce un solide train d'atterrissage
c'était un grand changement par rapport
au bf 109 qui avec son train
d'atterrissage et 3 et instable et est
extrêmement difficile à poser atterrir
sur un terrain sablonneux où cahoteux
avec un messerschmitt était un exercice
périlleux et beaucoup de nouvelles
recrues ce tuèrent en tentant cette
mineure
grâce à sa conception soignée
le 190 était un appareil facile entre
donner l'air par ailleurs un mode de
construction efficace les tronçons et en
construit séparément permettait à la
fois de le produire rapidement et avec
beaucoup de facilité
il était extrêmement résistant et même
en cas d'atterrissage d'urgence sur le
ventre la cellule eux subissaient peu
voire aucun dommage
en effet un blindage protéger à la fois
le pilote et le moteur et avec un
armement composé au minimum de six
mitrailleuses
la puissance de feu du fesf était
nettement supérieure à celle du match
plein le 190 était incontestablement
plus sûr que le sang neuf
le 190 était sans doute moins rapide
mais il disposer d'un très bon armements
il y avait quatre mitrailleuses
disposées autour du moteur elle était à
côté du moteur
vous observerez d'ailleurs que les
meilleurs résultats en combat sur une
journée et est généralement obtenus par
les 190 dans son dernier rapport
l'équipe décès indiqué que malgré le
manque de fiabilité de son moteur le f
w190 était nettement moins vulnérables
en situation de combat et qu'il
présentait un certain nombre d'avantagés
significatifs par rapport au bf 109 f
le faut que vous vous disposez d'un
moteur très résistant il était en lui
même très robuste et très bien conçu il
résistait très bien lors d'une attaque
certainement beaucoup mieux que le m 109
le feu que wulff avait un moteur à
refroidissement par air
tandis que celui du et me 109 été
refroidi par eau
dans ces conditions si un projectile
endommagé les circuits de
refroidissement
le ms en neuf étaient perdus alors que
le faux que wulff avec son
refroidissement par air le faux que
wulff était plus rapide à basse altitude
par exemple jusqu'à 6000 mètres mais au
dessus le m 109 lui était supérieur mais
la plupart des combats aériens ont
généralement lieu en dessous de 6000 m
le feu que vous bénéficiez donc là d'un
grand avantage
il était beaucoup plus robuste que le m
toutefois ils pouvaient présenter
certains inconvénients par exemple lors
d'un bombardement piqué à cause du
refroidissement par air et en fonction
de la vitesse il le ferait trop de
résistance à l'avancement ce qui a
affecté sa stabilité
parfois l'avion pencher d'un côté et
vous pouviez vous retrouvez alors dans
une situation désespérée vous perdiez le
contrôle
il était très difficile de le redresser
à la fin de l'année le rlm avait passé
une importante commande plus de 400
appareils d'autres commandes s'unir et
la demande excédait rapidement la
capacité de production des usines
foxconn un radeau fisler et ago reçurent
l'ordre du ministère de l'air de
produire cet appareil sous licence
dans ces conditions le rythme de
production augmentent a rapidement au
printemps 1942 il avait atteint le
chiffre de 250 exemplaires par mois
les premiers appareils furent affectés à
la jg 26 qui quelques semaines plus tard
compas trois escadrons de 190
entièrement opérationnel leur apparition
au dessus des côtes de la manche
constitua une surprise totale pour la rr
une fois que bull peut surclasser
aisément le spitfire marque 5 et après
plusieurs succès significatif
ses adversaires lui donnèrent alors le
surnom de butcher bay l'oiseau boucher
en février 1942
le nouveau chasseur participe à sa
première opération de grande envergure
l'opération cerberus le 11 à 23h02
croiseur cuirassé le scharnhorst et la
guinée-bissau à paris hier depuis le
port de brest accompagné du croiseur
lourd prins eig et de navire était
chargé d'ouvrir un passage jusqu'à 12
après avoir quitté les eaux britanniques
ils devaient ensuite rejoindre leurs
propres bases à villaines savane
leur route était découpé en cinq
tronçons distincts et la luftwaffe été
chargée de leur procurer un appui aérien
constants commandé par adolphe galant
les fois que woolf de la jg 26 et le
messerschmitt de la jg deux leur assure
une couverture depuis le havre jusqu'à
l'embouchure du rhin billet vert à
willems havane ces navires furetais de
corte par les chasseurs de la jg 1
toutefois le 12 février peu de temps
après midi ces bâtiments furent repérés
par une patrouille d'avions de
reconnaissance britannique pendant les
24 heures qui suivirent il allait
devenir la cible de tirs côtier
d'artillerie de plusieurs attaques de la
royal navy et de raids de bombardements
répétés de la rff et de l'aéronavale
britannique
néanmoins toutes ces attaques pourraient
être repoussées
au cours d'un seul raid la jg 26
détruisit si bombardier lance-torpilles
emblée nommé sword fiche la luftwaffe et
abattu un total de 49 à lions
britanniques contre la perte de
seulement quatre appareils
en avril 1942 la jg 2 devint la seconde
escadre de faux que wulff entièrement
opérationnel de la luftwaffe lors des
quatre mois suivant cet appareil à les
dominer le front occidental et devant
l'augmentation constante de ses pertes
la rff s'alarme grâce à une version
chasseur bombardier et du fw 190 la jg 2
et la jg 26 par woerth a frappé avec
succès différentes cibles sur le
territoire britannique
après le malheureux débarquement de
dieppe
ces deux ex-cadres rapportèrent avoir
détruit près d'une centaine d'appareils
britannique
la réaction de la grande-bretagne cet
oiseau boucher ne se fit pas attendre
avant la fin de l'année rolls royce
réussi à mettre au point un nouveau
moteur avec compresseur à double étage
le merlin 61
lorsqu'il fut installé sur le spitfire
marque 9
la situation se modifier radicalement
malgré sa ressemblance avec le marque 5
le marque 9 devint la version de
référence du speed faire
celle-ci bénéficier d'importantes
améliorations par rapport aux versions
précédentes et grâce à un niveau de
performance fortement accrue elle se
montrait tout à fait à la hauteur du
sang neuf
f ou du fw 190
douglas bader un as de l'aviation
britannique décrit la réaction de johnny
johnson le plus grand âge de la ras
lors de sa première rencontre avec ef
w190 unis est arrivé nous annonçait
qu'il avait vu un nouvel avion allemand
avec un moteur en étoile et des ailes au
bout carey s'était montré nettement
supérieur aux spectateurs
et cela dans tous les domaines ensuite
un membre des services de renseignement
est arrivé et a déclaré nous pensons que
ce doit être un vieux curtis que les
américains ont vendu au français gianni
alors si ces vieux curtis sont aussi
performants que cela ne pourriez vous
pas nous en donner s'il vous plaît ils
ont découvert quelques semaines après
que c'était le focke wulf 190 par la
suite les constructeurs britanniques ont
doté le spitfire d'un nouveau moteur
c'était la version marque ne cet
appareil a dominé tout le reste de la
guerre il était meilleur que le 190 dans
tous les domaines
le spitfire était supérieur mais tout
dépendait également du genre de tour que
votre adversaire qui s'apprêtait à jouer
lorsque le spitfire marque 5 est devenu
opérationnel
nous étions plus rapides en outre elle
nous étions également capable de voler à
très basse altitude dans ces conditions
le spitfire ne pouvait pas nous
rattraper alors de nouveaux modèles de
spitfire sont apparus avec des moteurs
toujours plus performants
par exemple les merlin de rolls royce
ils ont donc repris l'aventage car il
était plus rapide et pouvait voler à
plus haute altitude que nous devions
rapidement mettre au point quelque chose
de plus performants nous avons alors
développé un système d'injection d'un
mélange au méthanol
ce fut une amélioration de plus de 60 70
voire 80 chevaux
nous avons alors repris l'aventage sur
le spitfire
deux mois plus tard la jg 51 allait
devenir la première et ce cadre de la
luftwaffe employés le faut que vous le
feu 190 sur le front de l'est la jg 54
suivi peu de temps après en janvier 1943
les quatre escadrille de la jg 51
avaient toutes reçues la toute dernière
série à 4 dès qu'ils entrent en action
les phoques wulff comment certes
immédiatement infligé de lourdes pertes
aux unités terriblement sous équipés de
la force aérienne russe en seulement 48
heures à la fin du mois de février la jg
51 abati 89 appareils soviétique
les russes avaient un grand retard leurs
pilotes n'étaient pas formés à la
tactique de plus ils veulent et sur des
avions complètement dépassés qui devait
dater de la guerre d'espagne leur
escadron de chasseurs se composait
essentiellement de chf 16 et 2 ch 15 v
ni plan dans ces conditions les russes
ont enregistré d'énormes pen lors de la
bataille de koursk en juillet la
luftwaffe à lens à la destruction de 450
nouveaux appareils
cependant malgré ces succès la guerre
aérienne à l'ouest commencé à tourner à
l'avantagé des alliés à la suite de la
conférence de casablanca en janvier 1943
la campagne américaine de bombardements
de jour commençait à s'intensifier
sensiblement les raids augmentèrent à la
fois par leur taille ainsi que par leur
fréquence et lorsque les bombardiers
quadrimoteur commencèrent d'un
s'enfoncer davantage au dessus de
l'europe occupée la luftwaffe celui
contrainte d'assumer un rôle défensif
ces ressources se trouvèrent alors
réduite au minimum et pour pouvoir
répondre à cette menace de nombreuses et
ce cadre de chasseurs dur d'être
rapatrié en toute hâte depuis d'autres
théâtres d'opération à ce moment là pas
moins de cinq versions différentes et
est disponible pour le phoque aux bulls
celle-ci lui permettait d'en porter une
grande diversité d'armements et
d'équipements spécialisés
baptisé route stadt chaque kit présenté
une combinaison différente
identifié par un numéro de r en 1943 la
campagne de bombardements de jours des
américains gagné en intensité et
beaucoup d'unités de fw 190 quittait
d'autres théâtres d'opération pour venir
défendre le territoire allemand le type
de missions variées en fonction de la
situation
si seuls quelques chats se rapprochait
n'y déco lyon avec quatre appareils mais
s'il y en avait davantage ou bien tout
un groupe et nous déco lyon alors avec
huit à douze appareils par mission
durant l'automne 1943 la luftwaffe
remporté à quelques-unes de ses plus
grandes victoires face aux bombardiers
américains le 1er août 55 bombardiers
lourds furent abattus au cours d'un raid
contre les installations pétrolières de
ploiesti en roumaine
deux semaines plus tard les américains
lancèrent une attaque contre les centres
industriels de regensburg et de
steinfort
ces deux cibles se situer bien au delà
du rayon d'action des chasseurs alliés
dès lors les bombardiers privé d'escort
se retrouvèrent seul pendant deux heures
face à une louve photographe déchaînés
77 furent perdues lors du premier raid
le 17 août est à peu près un mois plus
tard encore 60 autres bombardier ne
purent rejoindre leurs bases après un
second raid très destructeur les pilotes
de la luftwaffe utiliser différents
types d'armes et de tactique contre le
flot incessant de bombarder américains
et britanniques
certains chasseurs pouvez lancer des
requêtes de 210 mm placés sous chaque
aile d'autres venaient se placer au
dessus des grandes formations de
bombardier avant de larguer des bombes
de 250 kilos
nous tentions à cette époque constamment
d'améliorer l'efficacité de nos
chasseurs
c'était la même chose pour nos ennemis
lorsque les forteresses volantes ont
fait leur apparition nous avons dû
trouver de nouvelles armes pour les
combattre et c'est comme cela que nous
avons commencé à utiliser des roquettes
pour faire face à la campagne de
bombardements de nuit de las rf3 escadre
de 190 adopté une tactique particulière
baptisée le vil dosage des équipes
étaient chargés de repérer plus de
braquer le projecteur sur le bombardier
qui était alors détruit par les
chasseurs en dépit de l'obscurité tout
appareil éclairé par ces faisceaux de
lumière devenait une cible facile les
unités de reald aux entrées en action à
partir de l'été 1943 par la suite avec
l'apparition du radar naxos leur
efficacité allait fortement s'amplifier
une fois acquise la maîtrise du ciel la
nuit elles étant dire leurs opérations
en effectuant des missions
d'interception le jour par mauvais temps
j'ai été affecté près de göteborg dans
la 304e escadre de chasse deux jours
j'étais alors ce qu'on appelait un
chasseur à haute altitude
nous nous déplacions beaucoup dans
l'ouest au moment de la sphère d'arnhem
j'ai pris la chose très à coeur
alors j'ai été abattu près de risch les
nausées
je dois dire que ces appareils ont été
pour moi l'expérience la plus difficile
de toute ma vie de pilote
lorsque vous pilotiez un avion emportant
un très lourd armements et que vous
deviez attaques et des avions de
transport et qu'en plus vous saviez
pertinemment qu'il y avait des êtres
humains à l'intérieur c'était vraiment
une expérience terrible
en 1943 la luftwaffe se retrouva au
sommet de sa puissance
au milieu de cette année là l'allemagne
disposer de plus de six mille appareils
sur la ligne de front la production de
foca wulff s'était nettement intensifiée
et à l'automne près de 5000 avions
avaient été construits entre 1942 et
1944 la production totale pour tous les
types d'avions militaires progressent à
au rythme de 60 % par an pendant ce
temps là sur le front de l'est
hitler avait lancé l'opération citadelle
l'issue de cette offensive de grande
envergure qui visait à détruire les
forces russes déployées à koursk jouera
un rôle décisif pour l'avenir des
combats sur le front de l'est
2500 panzer bénéficiaire d'un appui au
sol de huit escadrons de chasseurs
comprenant à la fois dfw 190 et des bf
nous avons une grande surprise il avait
réussi à établir une nouvelle ligne de
production bien au delà de la portée de
nos bombardier elle devait se trouver en
aval de la chaîne de l'oural
en tout cas dans cette zone mais ils
avaient réussi à produire entre temps
une énorme quantité d'appareils ni
disposé de yack qui étaient de très bons
avions de chasse leurs pilotes étaient
également mieux entraînée depuis la fin
42 il avait réussi à mettre sur pied de
véritable unité d'élite
pourtant à elle seule les escadre de
chasse allemand de parvint à détruire
près de 450 à paris soviétique pendant
sept jours d'un combat quasiment
continue
l'avancée allemande
en dépit de ce succès fut néanmoins
stopper
qu est-ce qu constitue un tournant
décisif et pendant le restant des
combats sur le front de l'est les
panzers de hitler se retrouvèrent sans
cesse en position défensive
en 1944 la russie s'était doté
d'appareils nettement plus performant
la situation n'était plus comparable il
était très difficile de les abattre car
ils étaient lourdement blindés aussi
bien sans le fuselage salariés il
fallait se présenter par l'arrière est
visé avec une très grande précision pour
les coucher je connais beaucoup de
pilotes que toucher leurs cibles et
qu'ils ont constaté que l'avion volait
toujours
l'impossibilité pour les chasseurs
allemand d'arrêter les appareils
soviétique comme le stormreach influence
a certainement le cours des batailles de
chars sur le front de l'est
en février 1944 les bombardiers
américains reprirent leur campagne de
jours
mais cette fois escorté de chasseurs à
long rayon d'action
la huitième air force lansade de
nombreux raids contre les usines de
phoques wulff bmw est monsieur schmitt
les moyens de défense de la luftwaffe
était une fois de plus réduites au
minimum et dans l'espoir de redresser la
situation
fois que wulff format sa propre unité de
chasseurs pour assurer la défense de ses
usines
cette petite escadrille de pilote
d'essai participe à certaines opérations
afin de défendre l' usine de brême
qu'autant que lui même pris part à
plusieurs missions
mais le ministère de l'air soucieux de
sa sécurité fini par l'en dissuade avec
l'intensification de ces raids de plus
en plus de chasseurs étaient détruits au
sol avant même d'avoir pu être livrée
aux unités opérationnelles
désespérée la luftwaffe mis sur pied une
autre unité d'élite et je tombe staffel
drame les gars
chaque pilote qui la rejoignent et se
voyaient attribuer un faux que wulff 190
logements blindés ce pilote étaient
formés aux techniques d'abordage et il
devait abattre au moins un bombardiers
alliés lors de chaque mission
d'interception
à côté de cela d'autres focke-wulf
reçurent divers un moment si bombardier
et antichars les sg 116 par exemple
était équipé de trois ou six cannes
antibes 103 installé en position
verticale sur la partie supérieure du
fuselage
baptisé la douche ce dispositif était
conçu pour abattre des bombardiers en
les frappant par en dessous
grâce à une cellule photoélectrique les
canons de 30 mm et est automatiquement
déclenchée par l'ombre du bombardier
lorsque ce dernier surplomber le
chasseur
avec un équipement plus ou moins
comparable
seul le nombre et la détermination
pouvait faire la différence et c'est
bien ce qui se produisit dans le ciel de
l'europe occupée avec l'épée 51 et lés p
47 américains d'une part et les spitfire
marque 9 britannique d'autre part la
supériorité aérienne change a
définitivement de camp le plus grand
casse américain de la seconde guerre
mondiale francis gabris qui a volé sur
les spitfire 9 p 51 et p47 spitfire a
été principalement conçu comme chasseurs
intercepteurs et l'excellent est
véritablement dans ce rôle néanmoins il
avait ses limites ne disposait pas d'un
long rayon d'action
il n'était pas fait pour l'endurance
pour l'émission des scores qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas aller au delà des coupes
française et c'était à peu près tout
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
fini par recourir au p 51 op 47
sans oublier bien sûr le p 38 ans les
longues missions je dirais que le p 51d
certainement le meilleur avion car il
disposait d'un plus grand rayon d'action
que le p 47
le p 47 étaient limitées là explique le
rôle qu'a joué le p 51
toutefois nous avions des p 47 car ces
appareils disposait d'une énorme
puissance de feu par rapport aux p 51 10
n'avait que six mitrailleuses
aucun appareil dans le monde ne
disposait d'une aussi grande puissance
de feu de plus c'était un avion
extrêmement robuste n'était construit
comme un tank et je pouvais en faire
quasiment ce que je voulais il était
tout à fait à la hauteur du faux que
wulff 190 n'était ni même supérieur ou
et 209
disposions d'un système d'injection
d'eau qui augmentait notre puissance
disons de 3 à 5 minutes
tout dépendait de la manière dont on
l'utilisait cependant cela nous procurer
un énorme avantage par rapport aux
avions de la luftwaffe
tout au long de la guerre le fw 190
excella dans son rôle de plateforme
polyvalente d'armement c'est est
l'appareil idéal pour les opérations à
passer moyenne altitude en revanche dès
qu'il dépassait les 7000 m les faibles
performances de son moteur devenait
alors un handicap insurmontable tenta de
remédier à cela en travaillant sur de
nouveaux prototypes équipés tous les
deux de moteurs plus puissants les
prototypes de la série b utiliser un
système d'injection de monoxyde d azote
le gm tandis que ceux de la série c
était équipée d'un moteur daimler-benz à
turbocompresseur
les deux versions comprenait un cockpit
pressurisé mais aucune d'elles ne se
révéla suffisamment fiable pour être
produite à grande échelle
mes performances à haute altitude
demeurèrent un problème constant jusqu'à
l'arrivée de la série des en 1944
content qu avait résolu le problème de
la puissance d'une autre façon le junker
you 88 était un bombardier polyvalent
qui utilisé différents moteurs dans le
humo 213 ce dernier ressemblait à un
moteur radial il était en réalité un 12
cylindres en v avec un radiateur
circulaire placé derrière les 10
contrairement aux daimler benz le yom on
était quant à lui parfaitement
disponibles et sans la moindre
hésitation tank décida de l'installer
sur le 190
faut que wolf commença ainsi à mettre au
point ce qui aurait bien pu devenir le
meilleur avion de chasse de toute la
seconde guerre mondiale
dans le souci d'équilibrer l'appareil le
fuselage arrière fut allongée de 1 m 35
et doté d'une plus grande dérive dans
paint âge lorsque le prototype effectué
son vol inaugural à la ghana gun en mai
1944 il connut un succès immédiat avec
une vitesse maxi de 685 km heure il
était plus rapide que tous les autres
190 et cela à n'importe quelle altitude
il disposait d'une meilleure vitesse
ascensionnelle d'une meilleure
accélération et d'un plafond pratique
nettement plus élevé dans les cas
d'urgence
un système d'injection au méthanol mw 50
permettait d'obtenir momentanément un
gain de puissance de près de 30 % dans
l'ensemble la nouvelle version bénéficié
de très nette amélioration par rapport à
ses prédécesseurs
les pilotes considérèrent bientôt le
190d comme le meilleur chasseur à moteur
à pistons de toute l'histoire de la
luftwaffe
cependant cette année-là l'armada
aérienne de l'adversaire devenait
écrasante face aux faibles d'unités de
chasseurs allemands le 9 avril 1944 à
des raids de bombardement américain bien
ciblé détruisirent 70% de lusine faut
que wulff à marine
deux mois plus tard lorsque les alliés
débarquaient en france ils furent
soutenues par une force de plus de
quatre mille chasseurs et chasseurs
bombardiers pour affronter cette énorme
flotte aérienne l'allemagne comptait
moins de 300 chasseurs opérationnel
stationnés en normandie la crête d'un
second débarquement dans le pas de
calais eu pour effet de maintenir les
renforts de la luftwaffe en dehors de la
zone de combats pendant encore dessus et
lorsque ceux ci furent enfin arrivé
berlin en donna qu'on limite à les
opérations de combat au maximum afin
d'économiser le carburant le 20 juin 15
escadre de faux que wolf était à même
d'intervenir sur le fond du débarquement
malgré les difficultés celle-ci parvint
a infligé de lourdes pertes aux alliés
mais bientôt tous les terrains
d'aviation allemand situé aux portes de
la normandie et se retrouvèrent sous un
feu continu
au bout de quelques semaines la
luftwaffe avait perdu près d'un millier
d'avions et lorsque les alliés
entamèrent leur avancée les dernières
unités de chasseurs allemands se
replient hier pour défendre le
territoire national
en octobre hitler présente à des plans
en vue d'une reprise en main de la
situation à l'ouest avec une attaque
surprise à travers la forêt des ardennes
il espérait se frayer un passage jusqu'à
la côte
en prélude à cette offensive la
luftwaffe devait assurer la protection
des panzers en effectuant une série
d'attaqués contre les terrains
d'aviation allié le plan avaient été
méticuleusement étudié et le 1er janvier
1945 800 chasseurs des colères dans le
cadre de l'opération bodan plate conduit
jusqu'à leur objectif par des yeux 88
les f w190 et les m109 frappèrent 17
terrains d'aviation en belgique france
et hollande
les pertes les plus lourdes furent
infligée par l'ajc 26 à evere près de
bruxelles
avec l'effet de surprise plus d'une
centaine d'appareils alliés furent
détruits au sol mais ailleurs les
chasseurs allemands ne connurent pas une
si grande réussite h en belgique 13 fois
que vous lui ai dit monsieur schmitt
furent abattus par 12 thibauld de la
487e escadre de chasse un groupe de
spitfire du 131e ring en a bâti 20
autres pour une seule perte
en tout 93 chasseurs allemands furent
détruits au dessus des territoires
détenus par les alliés et lorsqu ils
tentèrent de regagner leurs bases
beaucoup d'autres furent abattus par
leurs propres défenses antiaériennes à
la fin de la journée
les pertes américaines et britanniques
s'élever à 250 appareils de son côté
l'allemagne avait elle perdu plus de 300
pilotes
c'était un échec tactique complet
tous les appareils alliés pour être
remplacée en quelques jours
mais la perte de pilote d'avion
constitua pour la luftwaffe un énorme
revers
je me souviens d'une histoire
l'appareil de notre commandant avait un
problème de radio et il n'arrivait pas à
la faire fonctionner c'est donc installé
dans mon avion
je suis partie environ une demi-heure
plus tard pour me rendre de karmann
akobo afin de le suivre à ce moment là
un groupe de mustang est apparu à côté
de moi devait y en avoir une douzaine
ils se préparaient tous à m'attaquer
mais grâce à mon expérience j'ai réussi
à leur échapper
ils ont essayé de revenir sur moi je me
suis servi alors de tout l'armement dont
je disposais j'ai tiré tant que j'ai pu
ces pilotes se sont réellement senti
frustré car il n'arrivait pas à me
rattraper
j'étais seul contre 12 j'ai réalisé que
j'allais bientôt manquer de carburant
j'ai alors décidé de plonger en piqué
vers la frontière russe ils m'ont suivi
pendant un certain temps mais comme je
volais basse altitude
ils n'ont jamais pu me rattraper mon f
w190 étant aussi rapides que leurs
avions tout en volant ensemble à très
basse altitude vers l'est
j'espérais qu'il réalise qu'il était en
train de violer l'espace aérien russe
elle ferait alors demi tour lorsqu'ils
s'en rendrait compte
une fois avoir pénétré profondément dans
l'espace aérien russe
effectivement les pilotes américains
grâce à cette j'ai pu une fois de plus
m'en sortir les uns après les autres les
généraux allemands se rendirent avec
leur unité
la dernière capitulation eu lieu le 7
mai et göring étant lui-même prisonnier
des alliés la résistance de la luftwaffe
pris à leurs fins en mars 1945
les russes avaient détruit toutes les
usines faut que wulff implantée à l'est
à l'ouest
elles avaient toutes subi d'énormes
dégâts et les bombardements alliés
intensives avaient par ailleurs détruit
la plupart des terrains d'aviation
allemand au début du mois d'avril
il restait moins d'un millier de f w190
en service au moment de l'effondrement
de ce pays quelques semaines plus tard
les alliés détruisirent systématiquement
les avions allemands en même temps
qu'une grande partie du matériel de
guerre nazi dans toute l'allemagne
occupée les services de renseignement de
l'us air force des pêcheurs de collecter
des échantillons de la technologie
allemande avant leur destruction par les
soldats en retraite
ainsi ses services pour mettre la main
sur des dizaines de fw 190 qui allait
être soigneusement examinés et comparés
ces quelques images montrent un oeuf
w190 transportés aux états unis pour y
subir de plus amples investigations
je l'aimé beaucoup car ils étaient
résistants aux bus bien équipé et bien
armés par ailleurs le décollage et
l'atterrissage était très facile
son pilotage était un vrai plaisir la
planche de bord et est extrêmement
facile à lire
on peut dire que c'était un très bon
appareil ça ne fait pas le moindre doute
un jour
j'ai eu l'occasion de piloter le phoque
voulu au cours d'un entraînement j'ai
effectué très exercice pendant cinq
heures de vol
je fus très impressionné par cet
appareil gelé tellement apprécié que je
me suis ensuite portés volontaires pour
rejoindre le front avec une escadrille
de faux que vous je ne peux que répondre
positivement à cette question
le faux que wulff a bien été l'un des
meilleurs avions de chasse de la seconde
guerre mondiale gare
la décision d'adopter le fw 190 n'est
intervenue qu'après coup il devait
simplement servir de soutien au bf 109
fois que wulff ne put d'ailleurs le
produire que parce qu'il était équipé
d'un moteur en étoile technique alors
peu populaire chez les autres
constructeurs
ces ingénieurs parvient ensuite à
résoudre les problèmes d'aérodynamique
de cet avion
grâce à une plus grande puissance moteur
le moteur radial survécu finalement aux
critiques et il fut adoptée par les
constructeurs britanniques japonais et
américains
le f w190 est aujourd'hui considéré à
juste titre comme l'un des plus grands
chasseurs de l'histoire
bah